okay so let's start
so hi uh we are very happy to have
puerto me from ohio state
university sorry the ohio state
university
give our sixth and final talk for the
summer
puya received his phd at the university
of chicago
he held postdoc position at diamax in
the institute for advanced study as well
as
ud austin and he started
at ohio state um a year ago as an
assistant professor
his work focuses on pseudorandomness
analysis of boolean function
combinatorics
and io holder free analysis and today is
going to talk about
these beautiful works it constructs
pseudorandom generators
from polarizing random works this is
uh quite um inspiring uh
work that that already have several
follow-ups
and maybe we would mention a few of them
as well in the talk
so i'm very happy yeah thank you
abhishek um
and i want to thank you and uh prasad
and the organizers for organizing such a
great lecture series it's been
very nice watching all these other great
talks
i'm very happy to to talk uh today
uh as i wish i mentioned so this uh this
uh talk is about pseudorandom generators
and a new way to construct pseudorandom
generators
um so the main part of the talk is from
a joint work with ishan chatter padilla
who's at cornell university cabo
hosseini who's a postdoc
at cmu and shahardovit who's at ucsd
but uh so the talk this paper is
almost two years old now and there's
quite a few developments since then that
i will try to
mention them along the way um
okay um so
so the the context of the talk is within
pseudorandomness and computation
where we will have two key insights
where the first
point of view is that we will treat
randomness as a valuable resource that
we want to
try to use as less as possible just like
time and space so we would when we want
to solve problems we would like to
solve them using as few random true
random bits as possible
and the second insight is that from
experience repeatedly it has
randomness has shown itself to be a very
powerful tool if you want to
solve a problem with tools from
probabilistic method etc
and if you believe in these two points
of view a very natural
question that arises is uh whether we
can reduce or remove
the randomness that an algorithm uses
without
increasing other resources that it uses
by much for example without
increasing the time by much and
um and if we could answer this question
in uh various
instantiations of that it would be
really great because we could use the
power of randomness to solve problems
then you know use our answer to this
question to get rid of the randomness or
at least
reduce the amount of randomness that
that algorithm
uses um and
one general way to do that is and you
know famous examples of
these problems are whether we can uh
derandomize
polynomial time randomized algorithms or
logarithmic space randomized algorithms
in the two-sided or one-sided error
setting and one general way to try to
answer this question is to construct
pseudorandom generators um and
pseudorandom generators are powerful
tool
and and are a generic way to
de-randomize
algorithms or re reduce the randomness
that they use
and um the way they're defined is by
sort of forgetting about the input of
the algorithm so let's say that you
wanted you had an algorithm that you
want to derandomize
you only think of it as a function of
its random bits
so if it was using n bits now you're
dealing with an
n variant boolean function
and the pseudorandom generator is simply
another distribution on n bits that's
not uniform
but fools the algorithm so this function
f
that we had and by fools we mean that in
expectation
the outcome of f is very close to the
outcome of f
on the output of the generator so we say
that a generator
is a is a
okay it's a map from zero one to the s
to zero one to the n
so it's producing an n bits pseudorandom
distribution
using only s truly random bits
and s is called the seed of this
generator
the seed length of the generator
and ideally we would like s to be very
small compared to n
so the smaller the s the
the less randomness that this reduction
is going to
to have so our new algorithm will
basically instead of using
n truly random bits it will first
flip s coins and then plug it into g and
then use that as if it was its
randomness
and you can see that if we want this new
algorithm to also have
be computationally bounded we would
ideally need g to be easy to compute
and easy to compute is based on the
application that you have in mind if you
want to de-randomize log space
you want this to be you know small space
computable
et cetera
okay so
it will be easier and just for for the
formulas to be shorter to write the
pseudorandom generator to actually as
just a random variable
during this talk so we will just say a
random variable
over the boolean cube is a pseudorandom
generator
if the expectation of f under the
uniform distribution is close to the
expectation
of f under this uh pseudorandom variable
and it will also because a lot of the
tools we will use are going to be
analytic
it will be very convenient to think of
the boolean cube
instead of 0 1 to the n as minus 1 1 to
the n
okay so this will allow us to do things
like fourier analysis where
the characters will just become
monomials instead of
like one to the
sets etc um and we still think of x as a
pseudo-random generator so when we say
that it requires a small seed
uh what that means is that you can think
of x as the
output of some generator that uses as
truly random bits
in order to to generate these end bits
that we wanted
and pictorially you can think of it as
if this like three-dimensional
cube that we have is the the whole
n-dimensional boolean cube
you want to come up with a sparse subset
of its vertices
so which are these blue points in a way
that
no matter what function i pick from this
family of
the curly f family of functions that i
have
the expectation of that function over
the blue points
is going to be very close to its true
expectation over all of the points
so this is kind of a strong statement
because we have the same set of points
which is the support of x and it works
for all of the functions that are in the
family
okay so that's what that's why a
pseudo-random generator is kind of a
powerful tool it doesn't care which f
it's fooling it's going to give it the
same
distribution um and i forgot to mention
so if
at any part there's any questions please
stop me uh
the whole goal is to cover a lot of the
details and i
i hope that everyone can follow so
there's no very deep
uh stuff going um
so some examples of families of tests
that you would want to fool for example
if you want to de-randomize polynomial
time it suffices to
fool all politicized circuits or if you
want to de-randomize
block space it suffices to fool
all polynomial with read once branching
programs
but there are there are a family of
weaker or different classes that people
have
studied there's several papers written
so we we do care about
you know bounded uh depth circuits
bounded depth circuits with parity gates
half spaces polytopes um
uh you know a lot the list goes on
but i want to give you two examples of
very simple classes of tests
that turn out to be very important so
they have simple constructions but they
they turn out to play a very important
role in constructions of pseudorandom
generators
so the first one is the example of
k-wise independence
k-y's independent distributions so let's
think of
the family of tests that are cajon tests
so for now we are thinking of a family
of functions over
n bits right so so throughout the talk
uh
even though f will be an infinite family
so for
we will we will assume that it's just a
subset of n variant boolean functions so
now let's think of the family of n
variable tests
that ignore all but k of their input
bits
right so let's think of all of these
hunters
and we call it distribution k y is
independent if it's
uh if it perfectly fools this family
with error zero and this kind of
distribution
uh construction turns out to have very
close connections with coding theory
uh codes that have large distances and
through this connection
you can construct very good uh
pseudorandom generators for this family
uh with seed length that's big o and and
if you think about it
so once you fool all k
juntas what this really tells us is that
you have a pseudo-random distribution
over n bits
that if you look at any of the k bits
and you
only look at that window you have a
truly uniform distribution
right so the projection to any k bits is
truly uniform
so it does look like something that you
could use
other places and another really
central
[Music]
concept is the concept of small bias
generators
and this is where instead of look
pulling juntas we want to fool
all fourier characters which as i
mentioned so once we are over minus 1
1 to the n these are just the set of all
monomials over n variables multi linear
monomials because
x i squared is equal to x i if i if we
care about them as a function
um and initiating from the work of this
these were studied from
starting from the work of nauru and or
where they gave a very good construction
that achieves seed length log n over
epsilon
with error epsilon and the constants in
this construction have been improved
over the years
the best of which being a work of amnon
tajsma from a few years ago
but how do we construct pseudorandom
generators
for other classes of functions
surprisingly i want to claim that there
isn't that many ways
so in fact in a high level there's only
three ways we know how to construct
pseudorandom generators
the first of which so each of them very
fruitful
the first of which not that related to
this talk is
the hardness versus randomness
phenomenon where we
assume that we have a function that's
really hard for the class that we want
to fool and try to use it as a gadget
into constructing a pseudorandom
generator that stretches
few bits to more bits
the second way is to just pick one of
these basic generators that we already
have constructed
such as small bias distributions or ky's
independence and just
realize that that's just enough for
to fool this class of function tests
that you have at hand
and it turns out that this works
sometimes for example
you know the famous example that
braverman showed that
ky's independence fools bound the depth
circuits
or we know that bounded wise
independence fools
have spaces and the third maybe
you know broader way of constructing
pseudorandom generators is
well maybe one copy of an epsilon biased
distribution doesn't fool your family
what if i used several of them and put
them together in some sort of clever way
you can see that this is a little bit
more loosely defined this third category
and you can put a lot of different
things into this
so one simple example of this is the
result of viola
who showed that if i
just take the xor of d copies of uh
epsilon bias generators uh that will be
able to full
degree d f two polynomials right
so this is a very simple way of putting
together just this small bias generators
and
it turns out to it can actually full
degree df2 polynomials
um but again because i sort of loosely
defined this
this area so there's other
really powerful methods that kind of
fall into the same way
right so there's this method of
pseudorandom restrictions that was
initiated by i thai and victors and
and uh avishai a few weeks ago gave a
very nice talk
and if you're interested in learning
more about it you should
go check that out in the workshop at
stock
so so the method of pseudorandom
restrictions is well
you know instead of extoring the this
small base generator is what if we just
keep picking subsets of the end bits
that we want to generate
in a pseudorandom way and fill them in
using these basic generators that we
have and keep repeating until we have an
end bit to the random distribution so
again so sort of the constructions are
simple the analysis is usually harder
because you have to somehow show that it
and this talk
in in a way falls into this category
also so we will show how to construct
the pseudorandom generator using simple
building blocks
but what makes this new method
slightly fall outside of this number
three
framework is that the building blocks
are going
to be a new kind of objects that we
define
um so we will define these new building
blocks that we call
fractional prgs which pictorially i can
i can show it in this way so you know a
prg
was required to pick vertices of the
cube
but well we require we allow a
fractional prg to pick points that are
inside of the solid cube
this at the first glance may not make
any sense so we have a boolean function
how do we even evaluate it and so on
um so let's see how do we formalize this
kind of intuition
um so for now uh let's assume that we're
given a family of boolean functions
and various boolean functions that we
want to fool
and we want to come up with the actual
pseudorandom generator
such that the expected value of f of x
minus expected value of f
is at most epsilon
so we are dealing with a family of
boolean functions
and almost always the one of the right
first things to do is
write its free expansion and and see
what we can
we can deduce from there right so one of
the first things that it does
so so the fourier expansion looks like
something like this so you have the
empty fourier coefficient
and you have a fourier coefficient for
any non-empty subset of the indices
you have a real coefficient f hat of s
and you have these monomials products of
x i which are the characters
um so the first simple observation here
is that if you look at the expected
value of f over the uniform distribution
everything here just vanishes
and you get f hat of empty so well
didn't do so much but at least it we can
rewrite
the definition of a prg by saying that
i want to come up with a distribution x
such that this expectation
approximates the empty fourier
coefficient but i want to do something
more now that
that's going to be interesting
so we wrote this fourier expansion of f
here
and at this point we can forget about
the fact that f was boolean
right we have a polynomial at our hand
right now over n variables
and we can plug in any real numbers that
we want to
um and we know that this polynomial is
multi-linear because
x i's appear with powers 0 and 1.
so this is what we call the multi-linear
extension of f so now we have a function
that
takes values inputs from r and
and produces the real number
and having this we can define this sort
of
you know maybe look silly at first but
it will have meaning later
so we will define a fractional prg to be
any
random variable that takes values in the
solid cube
and the expected value of the
multi-linear extension of f
over x is close to f of zero
and you can see that once we think of
the extension of f
of zero is really f hat of empty set
that's why i replace the
f hat of empty set with f of zero right
so this is a definition that's that now
makes sense um
[Music]
and just to have some intuition of
how you know how these things work so
let's just look at a simple example so
let's think of
this two-variate boolean function that's
on
and of two bits so x one
and x two is going to output one only if
both of the inputs are one
and you can check that the fourier
expansion of f is of this form
so the empty fourier coefficient is
minus one-half
so this polynomial produces the right
the correct
outputs on the boolean inputs but we can
actually evaluate it on
any real numbers and in fact if you just
focus on the solid cube so if i plug in
one-half and one-half i get one over
eight if i plug in zero and zero i get
the expectation
right and this is what we will use and
what we used in the definition of the
fractional prgs
and this sort of the multi-linear
extension of
f has very nice properties that will
allow us to
to to to make meaning of what does it
mean for
evaluating the extension at the run at
some point
a in the cube not just the all zeros um
so the very simple but useful fact about
the extension of f
is that if i look at the expectation of
f
on a random variable that has a product
distribution
so i have some x that has a all of its
variables are independent
then by multi-linearity and linearity of
expectation
expected value of f on x
is the same as f evaluated at
expectation of x
right so you can just bring the
expectation inside because everything is
independent and you just get
f the extension of f evaluated as
expectation of x
as input variables um
why is this useful it's useful because
if i'm given some arbitrary vector
inside of the solid cube
this idea allows me to write f of a
as an x as some sort of expectation of
f evaluated at the vertices of the cube
and the way to do it is to come up with
a random variable that has a product
distribution
uh expectation of which is a i so one
way to
achieve it is to output you know for to
fix each coordinates to e to equal to
one
with probability one plus a i over 2 and
minus 1 with probability 1 minus a i
over 2. so if you take the expectation
you just get
ai and
you can also sample this so depending on
the problem that you're working there's
there's different ways
to sample the same distribution so you
could also say
i want to you know output
sine of a i with probability
absolute value ai and
just output a uniform bit otherwise
and and this will also have the same
it's the same distribution it's just a
different way to look at it so
you know depending on how the kind of
problem that you're trying to think
about
um so
so what this told us is that f of any
point in the solid cube is just some
expectation of f evaluated at the
vertices of the queue
and again so pictorially
let's say i have a boolean function on
the whole
0 minus 1 1 to the n so let's say this
is the red points are the evaluations of
f
on those red points a prg is just a set
of blue points
that such that the expected value of f
over those points so here it's one third
it's one-third plus one-third minus
one-third
it's close enough to f evaluated at the
center of the cube
and in in the definition of nf
prg we allow picking the blue points
inside of the queue
okay and ideally this should help and
you should by now have realized that
this will help too much
um i haven't restricted what points do
we pick and we want to approximate
the value of f at the center so why not
just pick the center
and if you pick the center you will have
an error
zero and you will actually fool all
boolean functions
right so there's some restrictions we
should put if we want to make this
useful
and in the rest of the talk i will show
that if you add some non-triviality
assumptions
then fractional prgs are useful and
in what sense in the sense that they we
can actually use them to construct
actual prgs um so the zero fprg is not
useful
whatever this non-triviality is um
and and then in the next part of the
talk i will
convince you that fprgs are easier to
construct
in some sense than prgs by giving you
generic constructions of fractional prgs
from
some assumptions on fourier tail bounds
or assuming that the family of functions
simplifies under
rand like truly random restrictions
okay so let's move on to
how to construct prgs using fractional
prgs
so now we will assume that we have
access to a fractional prg
i'm not going to for now care about how
it's
constructed so we are just given a
random variable
that takes values inside of the solid
cube
and we want to cons that and that it
epsilon fools the family that we want
and we want to construct an actual prg
and the general idea will be to define
some sort of
random walk inside of the solid cube
that converges to the vertices of the
cube
and we will think of the out the you
know the
end points of this random walk as the
prg
and we will show that this this works
and it's easy to see that the first step
of this random walk is easy to define so
first of all
let's agree that the center of the cube
is the the right the correct starting
point
and that's because f of 0 is what we
want to approximate anyway right
so if we start there we know that at the
at the center we don't have
any error and we are given this
random variable x the expected value
which
is close to the f evaluated at the
center so why not just jump to that x
um and and next we will show that we can
actually continue this walk
somehow right um and
we can't just simply keep adding x
independent copies of x because then it
will
be hard to argue you could jump outside
of the cube etc
so we will have to do it in a very in a
careful way
and we will need two assumptions to be
able to
both continue this random walk and to
make some sense
some sort of progress so progress to us
will be
to with high probable to get closer and
closer to the
vertices of the cube and this will
require
x to be non-trivial to have some sort of
very like
uh you know large variances on its
coordinates
and to be able to make progress we will
make one assumption that
f the family is closed under fixing its
inputs
so let me just formally define these two
conditions that we need
so the non-triviality condition we call
it p
noticeability we say that a random
variable
x is p noticeable if all of its
coordinates
have you know some larger
than p variance and an important
example to keep in mind is a random
variable that's basically p
times some true boolean vector so it's a
random variable all of coordinates of
which are minus p or p to the n
and this will be p squared noticeable
okay
so this this square actually becomes
important in some applications
um and this closeness under restriction
so i have to clarify so i
i promise you that we are thinking of f
as a family of functions over n
variables so what does it mean if i fix
some of the inputs it's still in the
family
so we will still think of it as a the
restricted function as a junta on
n variables it's just ignoring the fixed
input bits so we say f is closed if
if you pick any f in the family and you
fix some of the input bits
the new function is still in the family
okay
and pretty much all of the classes that
i mentioned in my earlier slides
have this property so it's i mean there
could be some interesting classes that
are not closed under restrictions
um but most of the the ones that we care
about
turn out to be closed under restrictions
okay and
here's the main theorem that uh that
shows this
reduction from fprgs to prgs
from prg stuff prgs which says that if i
have access to an fprg that epsilon
fools the family
and it's p noticeable and we are closed
under restrictions
then there is a prg of the form
some some gadget g applied to
t independent copies samples from
the fractional prg and
it's epsilon times t equals f and this
works if you pick
t to be roughly one over the
noticeability parameter
times log n over epsilon so this is the
analysis that i will show
and in fact if you're more careful you
can do a little bit better in terms of
dependence on epsilon and so on um
but but this is what we will show so
this version of the theorem is what you
mentioned
and this g is going to be our random
walk gadget
right so g itself is has no randomness
so all of the randomness of this
construction is just sampling
t copies of x1 up to x it's just t
independent copies of x so the seed
length will be just t
times whatever the seed length of x was
okay
so let's go back to this idea of the
random walk so we
agreed that we will start at the center
of the cube so
now i'm making it two-dimensional
because it's easier to
to visualize um and the first
step of the random walk we agreed that
it's good to just use a
x as the first step so how do we
continue and to see how to continue we
just need to argue that
if my starting point was at some point a
arbitrary point a how do i continue this
walk
with a new sample from x and
it turns out the right at least one way
that
that works is to look at the largest
sub cube that is centered at
a so we know how to move from center of
a cube
using x so let's make a at the center of
some other cube
that we don't jump out of the original
solid q
right so we look at the larger sub cube
that has this property
and we want to use x in some sort of in
a
scaled way to move inside of that cube
and to make that definition i will just
make these
two simple definitions so
given a vector a let's define delta a to
be just the distances of
each coordinate of a from the boundary
so this will be sort of the dimensions
of that cube
and let's define x circuit to be just
a coordinate wise product of the two
where
two vectors x and y so having that
at hand so it turns out that this is the
the right way to to make the next step
of the the walk
so we go from a
to a plus basically a new
a fresh copy of x but we
multiply each coordinate of x by you
know how much
could we making sure that's just we that
we're not jumping outside of the
original solid cube
so this is as large as we could multiply
by never
jumping outside of the key right so
that's the
that will define our random walk
and we need to see why this works
and the next lemma shows why this works
so it will show that
one step of such a random walk doesn't
cause much error
in approximating f of a so if i start at
any point a
and i jump from a to a plus delta a
circ x this x in expectation
i'm still close to f of a and for the
final walk we have to just apply this
lemma
t steps and apply some triangle
inequality
okay so how do we prove this
so the general idea is that well we know
that
the family f is closed under
restrictions
and i know that this distribution x
fools
all the functions that are in the family
so
if i can write this statement as
a linear combination as a convex
combination of
other functions that are in the family
but
centered at 0 instead of a then i'll be
done
because now i know that when center
that's 0 x fools all of those functions
in expectation so to make it formal
let's
let's make this definition so i will
define
a random variable r of x so
x is the input is some vector x
so r of x has a product distribution
its i-th coordinate is equal to
sine of a i with probability absolute
value a i
and it's otherwise it's just x i
okay so it's some sort of random
restriction
vector so with some probability we are
fixing that to a
i otherwise we're just taking x i right
so that's how it's defined
and you can see that the expectation of
r of x is exactly this vector that we
care about it's the next step of the
random walk
does that make sense
because the expectation is absolute
value of a
i times sine of a i which is just a i
plus
1 minus absolute value of a i which is
just delta a
i times x i right so it's exactly this
this quantity
um right so here so here um
i mean you use product distribution over
uh not necessarily boolean values right
so that's also okay
right so earlier we said that uh we
we would think of product distribution
over
boolean things but actually this would
have worked yes it works over rn as
yeah so we have multi-linear polynomials
that's that's true
um and now we will make this definition
of
so i will define a new boolean function
so it will take
f of it will take some input x
so this capital f of x
is a random function um for
any instance of r of x it will just
evaluate f on that
sort of restriction restricted function
right so this
f is a random function over restrictions
of
f because uh each
each of these rx's fix some of the input
bits to
this sign of ais but like but keep a
live sum of the excise
and now we're pretty much done so we
wanted to bound
f of a minus this f of a plus delta
a or x we can write both of them as some
expectation over capital f
right because we know that this
expectation is just this
um so we have expectation of f f of 0
and expectation over f and x of f of x
um
and this zero appears because when
you're putting the uniform
when you put x to be uniform
distribution the expectations just
become zero so it's as if you're looking
at r of zero
right so it's just f of c so now if you
bring out this
expectation over f outside
so you're looking at f capital f of zero
minus expected value of
over x of capital f at x
but remember that when you already
sampled f
it's just the restriction of lowercase f
and we know that x fools all of those
because the families close down the
restrictions
so you just have a bound on epsilon so
for
any of these capital f's this is bounded
by epsilon so the expectation is bounded
by epsilon also
okay so very very simple fact
and and you can see that we crucially
use the fact that the families close
down the restrictions because
um it wasn't enough that x only fools
the original
function lowercase f so we would need to
fill all of these restrictions
yes obviously so it seems that um
what you need is that there you know
this x falls
the function f and all the restriction
of the function f
right exactly exactly
um yeah that's true so you know so if if
you only wanted
to fool a specific f all what you need
is to to fool
all of the restrictions of it um so if
we wanted to come up with a random
walk that fools a specific function all
all that we care is like all of the
restrictions of that f
that's true okay
so so as i said so now we have this
lemma and we can apply it repeatedly for
i steps
and that says that if i define my random
walk using the formula that we had
so the steps are just using this
boundary
distance normalized copies of x
then the expected value of this random
variable which is just uh
where we arrive at after i steps of the
walk
is close to f of zero it's at most i
times epsilon because at each
step by dilemma incurs an error of
epsilon
okay so that's great so we have managed
to
define a random walk the error which is
decaying but it's not decaying by much
but remember we wanted a an actual prg
so currently this random walk there's no
guarantee that it's going to reach
actually the vertices of the queue
and we will finish this construction by
showing
two new ideas so the first one is the
concept of
polarization so we show that this random
walk is actually polarizing
meaning that it will get very close to
the vertices of the cube
quickly so in logarithmic amount of
number of steps
we get very close to plus minus one and
and next we show that well once you're
close enough then just rounding to the
nearest plus or minus
one actually doesn't anchor much uh
error
okay we have another question yeah so
uh you you said quickly that this is
some kind of hybrid argument that there
is at most epsilon times t
is it is it tight i mean it seems that
maybe you know if we think of
errors like sometimes cancelling each
other's out maybe
this scales like epsilon times square
root epsilon times
square root if i'm thinking of errors as
themselves as
a random wall right so oh i see
yeah i i don't know i mean it's it's
possible i don't have a
like a lower bound i i think in terms of
t
and as i said so this dependence on
epsilon
also could be improved maybe so like the
number of steps you need
doesn't necessarily have to depend on
this badly on
epson um yeah thanks maybe we can talk
later
um okay so but but if we believe these
two new
ideas of polarization and rounding then
then our job is done so the generator
will be to
take t steps of the random walk that we
defined
and just take the signs of that that
vector
that we got okay
so how does polarization work so we will
actually
show that if x is non-trivial it's p
noticeable
and we will have to make one extra
assumption about
x and that is it's symmetric but
but this will not be very problematic
because if you have an x that's not
symmetric you can just
average between x and minus x and make
it symmetric and it will
still fool most of you know almost all
of the families that we care about
and what we show is that for every
coordinator of the random walk
uh the coordinate will get exponentially
close to one or minus one with
exponentially high probability
right um and this this
exponential exponentially small
probability of being away is good enough
that you can actually do a union balance
right so if we pick
t to be log n over epsilon over p then
you can show that all coordinates with
probability one minus epsilon will be
close
so how do we show this um first of all
this claim makes everything
one-dimensional even though we had an
n-dimensional random walk
now we are just narrowing our view to
one dimension so we have just a random
walk on a line
starting at zero and we have all these
uh you know single dimensional real
variables
and this is the random walk now
and we know that x i is a random
variable that takes values in
the one minus one and one interval and
it has expectation
that's at least p and we know that it's
symmetric so
for example its expectation is zero but
we will actually
use the full power of that symmetry
somehow
not just that the expectation is here
and
the key inequality in proving this
polarization
is that this walk always satisfies this
inequality it shows that one the
distance
at step i from the boundary is always
bounded by the distance at step i minus
1
multiplied by 1 minus x i so no matter
what the outcome of x i is this is going
to be true
for this particular random walk okay
and i'm not going to tell you why you
have to actually look at some case study
depending on where
where the previous step is and you know
just make sure that
this works so for example
this shows that in expectation
we don't lose much i don't know somehow
other
so in expectation because x i is
independent of
y i minus 1 we don't lose much so the
expectation of 1 minus x
i is just 1 right so it doesn't increase
but this is not good enough for showing
that we get very close to
zero very fast and the the trick to do
that is to take square roots and then do
the same argument
so what we do is we take the square root
of the distance from the boundary
and you can still use the independence
to write it as this product
and now you have this expectation of
square root 1 minus x i
for which you can write its taylor
expansion which
turns out to be all just different
powers of x i with a negative
coefficient
um and here comes where we use the
symmetry
so because x x is symmetric
uh all of the odd powers have zero
expectation
so the first non-zero power there is
just x a
squared term so you can upper bound all
of them had negative coefficients so you
can upper bound by this one minus
expectation of x i squared over 8
which this is exactly this noticeability
so we can bound it by 1 minus p over 8
which for convenience we just bound it
by e to the
minus p over 8. okay
and and once we have this we're pretty
much done so just
repeat this for two steps
so what what it shows is that the
expectation
of the distance at t step from the
boundary and the square root
is bounded by something exponentially
small in
minus t right
and now you apply a markov inequality
and
you know take the squares after the mark
so that's how
this polarization it's pretty simple
um and as i said so we can take t to be
you know sufficiently large and
uh you know after sort of like log n
over epsilon
over p steps all of the coordinates will
be
uh sort of epsilon over n
close to the one or minus one
so how does rounding work
um so for rounding so what we will show
is actually so
the difference between f evaluated at
any vector
x from f evaluated at sine of
x is always bounded by just the l1
distance from the boundary okay so
that's what we will show
and again we will show this we will use
this trick of
this defining a random variable the
expectation of which
is x and but it's
all of its points are boolean so even
though x is inside of the solid cube
so we will define this random variable z
that has expectation that's equal to x
and we know that f of x is equal to
expected value of
f of z right and one way to define it is
just
to have sine of x i with probability
absolute value x
i and the uniform bit otherwise
why is this helpful it's because we can
use this definition of f of x
to rewrite the inequality that we were
interested in so we wanted
f of x minus f of sine we can now write
it as an expectation over z of this
difference
but now z is also a boolean vector
so whenever z is equal to sine of x
we get zero contribution and whenever
it's not
it's at most two contribution so this is
bounded by
just twice the pro probability that
these two vectors are not the same so
remember sine of x is a fixed boolean
vector
um and the probability that z is not the
sine of x it's just by a
union bound the sum of one minus x i
over two
because with probability absolute value
x
i you know the coordinate is equal
otherwise we still have a one-half
probability of getting it right so the
probability of not getting it is just
one-half
and you get this two and two cancel and
exactly we have the rounding
claim is proved
okay to summarize
so combining polarization and
the rounding theorem so if we pick t to
be log n over epsilon over p
with high probability all the
coordinates are epsilon over n
close and by this theorem
just rounding y t to the closest boolean
vector
will cause epsilon times epsilon over n
error which is just epsilon
another epsilon for the just the
rounding step
um and now we have proved this
this reduction theorem so the the final
random walk will have an error t
plus one times epsilon and the things
that we used was a fractional prg that's
symmetric and it's p noticeable and
that the family f is closed under
restrictions
and and you can see that now the seed
length will be
log n over epsilon over p times the seed
length that
x required right
so if x itself was fully logarithmic and
somehow p is
also poly logarithmic when we get a poly
logarithmic seed length
pseudorandom generator out of the
fractional
prg okay
um okay can you explain a little bit
uh what what is the gadget here this
gadget
oh so the the gadget g is just
uh you know this whole algorithm that
will
it will samp it it takes as input t
copies of
just t real valued vectors and
it will define these y i's where y one
is
x one and y two is just the next step
and it does all
of that and it will output just sign of
the ts
step of that random walk right so once
you are given x1 and xt
everything is deterministic you just
look at what that random walk would go
to
and just output the sign of that that
final point in the
so that's the gadget g okay so it's not
as
simple as sort of maybe a random
restriction or something like that
it's still some way of putting them
together
but in any case it's sort of like work
coordinated by coordinates so
at least yes exactly yeah so you're
you're basically looking at each
coordinate of
these x i's the first coordinate of all
of the exercise determines the first
coordinate
of the output so it's kind of it's nice
in that sense
thanks is there is there a lower bond
for the number of steps needed for your
polarizing random mode
um i'm i'm not sure of
of lower bounds and i think that william
had some argument on
that that you can't get perfect prgs out
of this
or off the top of my head i i don't
know i i i think maybe for the
one of the like uh corollaries that
you'll have
um there is a lower bound because
otherwise you would get like a purge for
every boolean function
that is better than n or so
but which corollary like uh yeah you
haven't talked about it yet but
okay i see for for the fourier
coefficient stuff yes
okay um okay so maybe we discussed this
yeah thanks trouble for the it's a great
question
um well one question so you're doing
these uh prgs i mean obviously
you're assuming everything's over the
reels if you had
precision limitations and so on you just
have to have a basic generator
uh and then you're you're fine sort of
in the basic
uh generator um but i mean if these were
approximate in
in in any way if they were approx
approximate it still works because of
this rounding argument that we had right
so
uh you can go to the closest
approximation and the error that
that incurs is going to be bounded by
the l1 distance from
the you know the real points that you
wanted
um right so it's it's sort of robust so
you can
like round things um
up to error epsilon over n or something
and
and not cause much error to the final
generator that
it is true though that for now i have
been pretending we can do these
real calculations and in
you know in discrete time somehow that's
that's a good point
okay so so we we now know how to use
fractional prgs to construct prgs well
now we need to construct fractional prg
so i'm going to
tell you how to construct fractional
prgs
and i will show you how to construct
them using
some properties on some bounds on the
tails of the fourier coefficients of the
family
okay so let's think of these two
definitions
i will say that a family of boolean
functions satisfies
this l1 of a b fourier tail property
where a and b are just some parameters
if
for any k that's greater than or equal
to 1
the sum of the fourier coefficients in
the absolute value
at level k is bounded by some a times b
to the k okay and you can sort of forget
about a for now so let's think of
at the level k the l1 norm is at most b
to the k and
and we will define similarly the l2 l2ab
property to
to be that the l2 norm of the case
levels
for all levels is bounded by this time
something that's exponentially small
and the reason that you know here to
make it interesting we have to make this
exponentially small but we allow this to
be
something that can get really large is
that by parseval
the sum of all fourier coefficients
square of the fourier coefficients at
at all levels is at most one it's
exactly one because we have a
one minus one boolean function
so an interesting extra a stronger
property is that at level k we have this
exponential
decay right fact these two properties
turn out to be
related so avishai has this uh really
nice paper where
he has a tail where a table where he
also relates these
to random restriction lemmas the
probability that under random
restriction the degree drops and so on
um and he shows that the
l2 tail bounds imply the l1 tail bounce
but i also want to point out that the
reverse of this
is the inverse is not true uh and you
can see by just taking the parity
function
uh the parity function at the highest
level at the nth level
has l2 norm that is one so it can't
satisfy this
l2 bound for b that is small
um but but it satisfies
the l1a b for b equal to one right so at
all levels l1 is at most one
in fact most levels it's zero
so in fact any interesting family of
boolean functions you have that
is able to compute parity is not going
to have
this l2 property for good parameters but
it might
have this l1 property
and and we do know quite a lot of
interesting families
satisfy l1ab or l2ab and when i say
satisfy
of course if you're allow full freedom
on choosing b
all families will satisfy them
but uh when i say that i mean that like
for
non-trivial b so for example b being
only poly logarithmic in n
or something like that so we know that
the ac0 circuits satisfy the exponential
l2 tail bounds and we know
bounded with branching program satisfy
l1
bounds with b's being something like log
n to the w
we know bounded sensitivity functions
permutation branching programs etc and i
actually we conjecture that
degree df2 polynomials also satisfy
this with b that is roughly exponential
in d
like let's say 2 to the o of t
and that would itself imply some new
pseudo-random generators for for
f2 polynomials then and i will talk
about that later
okay um so we have this this property
that a lot of the families
of boolean functions satisfy so it would
be very nice to have
just one generator that fools any such
family of boolean functions and we will
do exactly that so we will show that
there is a generic fractional
pseudorandom generator
for all families that have these
fourier tail bounds and we will forget
about the family we only will use the
fact that
they satisfy this through your tailbones
okay
and the construction is a one-liner so
what we do is we will sample
a vector so let's say that we have a
family of boolean functions that
satisfies l1 of a b
and our construction will be just pick
a small biased distribution over minus
one one to the n
and normalize it by one over two b
where b is the parameter in the free
effect
and i claim that this is a fractional
drg and
why do we only focus on l1 bounds and
not
l2 bounds is because since l2 bounds
imply l1 bounce
so this is the most general statement so
this will
also be a fractional trg for any family
that has l2ab tailbones
so how do we analyze this
so should we take a break sometime too
should i plan for a break
and whenever you feel comfortable yeah
maybe after this we can take you back
okay um
so the first thing to notice is that
this is a non-trivial fractional prg
because all of its coordinates are just
one either one over two b
or minus one over two b and this was
exactly the kind of
special kind of p noticeable fprg that
we discussed
so each of its coordinates will have
variance one
exactly one over four b squared
so all that's left is to show that
this distribution fools all functions in
the class
right and the so any function f in the
class of
tests is fooled by this distribution
and we will do this by fourier analysis
so we remember that f of 0 was just the
empty fourier coefficient so this
difference is just the
expansion of f evaluated on the
non-empty
fourier coefficients
and we just do a
triangle inequality so we bring the
absolute values inside and you can
already see that this is really
perfectly set up for the construction so
here we just have some real value but
here we have
the product of excise which is
essentially the bias of this
vector y but
normalized by a bunch of one over two
b's
right so let's try to write that down so
this quantity is exactly the bias
of the vector y on the set s which is at
most epsilon over a
by our choice just normalize by 2b
to the size of s right each of these
x i's that appear here was 1 over 2 beta
times that sum y i so we get a this term
1 over 2 b
to the size of s and now all we do is we
break the summation based on the size of
uh
the the fourier coefficient um
and we get this fourier coefficient
divide so you bring the epsilon outside
you get the fourier coefficient divided
by a
times 2b to the k
and now we use this l1 tail bound so we
know that exactly what this is bounded
by
so the numerator the sum is bounded by
a times b to the k which
the surviving term is 1 over 2 to the k
so the whole thing is bounded by epsilon
right very very simple way to
construct and this is kind of i hope you
agree that this is kind of remarkable
that
you know we can this simply we didn't
think of what the family was all we used
was just the simple
calculations and now we have a
fractional prg
that is 1 over 4b squared noticeable
and by the random walk gadget we can
turn it into an
actual prg as long as the family is
closed under
restrictions okay so maybe this is a
good time to
to pause um
oh i want to just mention also the the
seed length of this construction so all
we
used all of the randomness that we used
was to sample this small bias
distribution
and you can do this with log n plus log
a plus log 1 over epsilon
and you can do you know if you care
to improve this you can you can do this
analysis slightly more carefully
by treating the large coefficients
separately and using
almost ky as independence and you can
make the dependence on and
log log instead of login okay
yeah and then so if you have any
questions please go ahead
so yeah do you have examples of these
parameters a and b
for some like usual classes are going to
show after the break
oh no i so i mentioned so for example
for
with w read once branching programs you
get
something like b is equal to log n to
the
w maybe minus one which i may be
remembers
better i think it's w minus one um
so you get something that's like poly
logarithmic noticeable out of this
so sadly as you can see as you can sort
of
compare if you look at uh at our paper
so i will actually show some of the
applications of this but
uh the prgs we get are not the most
competitive
seed lengths so you always are missing
a square somewhere or like you can do
more clever things by looking at the
family
um but i think it's sort of inherent so
if you want to have
one prg that fools all of these things
you can't hope that
it's going to be optimum in all of the
specific
families that you're applying it um but
there is a case of for example for
permutation
with w branching programs you have uh
this bound with b that is just uh
polynomial
the width right so the end and doesn't
appear and in that case we actually get
some uh
good like the best prg for those for
that case for example
yeah i guess maybe yeah so this is sort
of
some examples of the application
and i guess i guess another application
is for these low sensitivity
functions and this was before the
sensitivity conjecture was resolved now
we know that k was just full then
yeah so i had to like remove uh one line
from these applications
but but i guess so so before we knew the
sensitivity conjecture is correct uh
you know was proved as avisha is
pointing out
we didn't know any prg with polynomial
insensitivity seed length
and uh in fact avishai and i had a
you know two to the square root s
construction
um but using this uh pseudorandom this
polarizing random walks you can get
polynomial in s but now we know that
uh bounded sensitivity is just
equivalent to
polynomial in s degree so
you can just use cable-wise independence
it's still open whether you can get
linear dependence on the sensitivity
that's a nice question so i have
another comment so it seems that
everything that you're doing is specific
to brgs
so i guess uh even if you just wanted to
consider the hitting set generator
like which could be much easier it's not
clear how to to use your approach right
um yeah so i'm i'm not
quite sure how to yeah but i i think
that
there could be ways of formulating this
random walk to
to give you a hitting set um
but i'm not sure if it would give and
anything good question
there's a question in the chat
do you see the q a in the bottom i can
read it
i mean somehow i only see my shared
screen
but not oh i see i see if i go
are these l1a l1abn properties good
enough to cover
most of the commonly seen function
families
uh not necessarily so i i would say
there is a lot of families that we don't
know um this
you know for so one example as i
mentioned even f2
degree d polynomials we don't know this
l one a b bounds
for a reasonable uh b
um i will maybe go into the details in
the case of f2 polynomials but
yeah so there's definitely a lot of uh
you know even with w branching programs
this is a quite
a you know maybe a result from four
years ago or something that we had that
that is founded so
maybe just to mention that uh family
that doesn't have this property
are like like the majority function
doesn't have this property so one
example
so it can go it cannot go beyond tc0
exactly that's true
okay so let's take a break let's be back
in 10 minutes